The joe rogan experience or jail?
Man,
I was in the New York during the,
uh,
you know,
the hurricane sandy and we were talking
to us a little bit before the show,
but like you got a doomsday prep.
I mean like unfortunately I prepped for
the wrong doomsday but a which one did
you prep for?
I Dunno,
a invasion of clowns.
I prefer a good one.
Good one.
But annoying.
Like clowns will be everywhere and we
have to fight them off with like water
guns and stuff like that and wrappers.
Yeah,
exactly.
But in this was like just fucking,
it was like apocalyptic.
It really was.
That's hilarious.
I mean,
did you expect it to be like that?
It was a way crazier than you expect it.
You know,
the thing about New York
though is since nine 11,
like our first responders
are like top notch.
They really like step up.
They know what they do,
they got plants and
all that kind of stuff.
But nobody,
I guess expected like New York City,
a tsunami wave hitting us,
knocking out power for like two weeks.
And then there's like Staten Island
Jersey where they got it even harder.
But uh,
you take the power out of New York
City and you got Somalia basically.
It's just a freaky,
weird,
scary town,
you know?
Yeah.
It's really strange when
you see how easy the,
the,
the film that covers civilization
can be removed and peak power savage,
it's just becomes absolutely rival real.
So you really have to worry about
survival because the first responders are
excellent.
Don't get me wrong,
they're great,
they're overwhelmed,
there's just sheer numbers,
impossible to deal with.
There was parts of the city where like I
was just walking around and it was just
dark and like guys would roll up on you,
like you can't see him.
And I'm pretty good.
Like nick,
no one what's happening?
It got to roll up on me and I'm like,
Whoa,
this is like a Chuck Norris,
you know,
that scene and every chuck Norris movie
we still like in the factory in a box in
October.
It was like that kind of thing.
Like,
just weird,
scary faces and just sounds like to walk
around a street at night with no gun,
no gun.
I was like,
fuck,
what am I going to find him with sarcasm?
What's going on here?
Who were walking like to where you had
to go to and fro in your neighborhood and
there was no lights on for days.
No lights.
It I where I lived there was lights,
but when you like we did
shows at the comedy cellar,
which is in the village.
They had no lights up
until almost the last day.
And we're doing shows to generators,
which is kind of cool in a way but
bad cause it went out when I was on,
but uh,
and went out and all of these flashlights
and candles started popping out of the
crowd.
It was like that scene
in requiem for a dream,
you know that saying like whether like
asked to ask the flashlights on the check
and all that kinda stuff.
So it was really,
it was really a freaky show,
but it was a good show.
But when you're walking around
the streets you're like,
okay,
this is like,
you know,
what do I,
what can I fight?
Whoever comes at me with,
with a weapon and there's a lot of like
homeless people coming off of their meds
too.
So there's like they have
like the extra evil in them,
you know?
Oh that's right because they can't
get their meds cause there's no power.
So it was like Zombie Style Zombie.
I was walking dead kind of shit.
That's scary as fuck.
Now whizzer a lot of that.
Like was there a lot
of muggings was there?
It was,
there was some looting,
there was whatever.
But it wasn't like Katrina,
cause I talked to guys who were
in Katrina and they're like,
you know,
everybody's like,
this is our Katrina.
It's like fuck no,
this is like Katrina was
like the end of the earth.
That was the end of the world there.
That was like weeks and weeks and weeks,
no help,
you know,
and no power and it was
hot and all that stuff.
In New York it was a little
bit better than that.
That's for sure.
It.
So I can't,
but it's still,
it was bad.
She lets you know what can go wrong
in the biggest city in the world.
Yeah,
exactly.
When that happens,
when the biggest city in the world gets
essentially shut down for two weeks,
that's a real eyeopener.
Oh,
absolutely.
Let's,
you know,
like people trying to get into
the city and they had to do,
you know,
like buses and all the trains were like,
exactly like somebody should
a kayak through these tunnels.
Just do it.
Like let's say like I did it,
I didn't even think about what it
must be like at night with no power.
I didn't even think about it.
Parents stayed inside.
Yeah.
Not have left.
Well you kind of,
it's kind of like,
how do you see where you're going?
It's scary.
So unless it's a full moon,
how do you see where you go?
Exactly.
You know,
the scariest thing I saw was
when I was like driving around,
like I was in a cab and uh,
calves by the way were like
incredibly hard to get at that point.
But,
uh,
there was like a candle in a
window of a project and I'm like,
this is what it's gonna look
like after a nuclear winter.
Like just like one holdout guy in a,
in a project somewhere like,
um,
you know,
like Charlton Heston in the light,
in the Omega man kind of thing.
And you know,
uh,
I was like,
this is it.
This is what it looks like.
You know,
I was,
it freak freak a lot of people out.
But then I think the guests
thank freak them out even more.
The fact they couldn't get gas for
their generators in cars and shit.
They're online for like 12,
15 hours.
Talked to a friend who said he was online.
It was two 30 in the afternoon.
He had been there since
six in the morning.
And you still haven't gotten gas easily.
Easily.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
We never,
we never,
I don't think even the,
uh,
government,
local,
whatever state thought like
there's going to be a gas problem,
you know,
and nobody was ready,
so wow,
you need that gas for the generators too.
So Jesus Christ,
especially in bringing everyone down,
but it was getting the
material from it at all.
Oh yeah,
I've got time.
I mean like a,
you know,
the whole idea of like,
um,
you know,
basically uh,
doing uh,
shows like in New York,
like the top of the line like guys
who pull the most prone are like,
you know,
the hedge fund guys,
the club Dj,
you know,
the male model who's,
you know by or whatever.
But that week it was all like Renaissance
Fair skills like candle maker,
blacksmith,
you know,
any guy who could hook
a bike up to a light,
you know,
he would get like,
definitely at least the reach
around that Yukon man show.
Have you ever seen that show?
Those shows were important.
They have a generators
that work on waterflow.
Oh,
they take a generator,
they set it up at their camp.
They have a fish camp and
they put this generator,
they set it up and then they attach these
tubes to it and they stick to tubes in
the creek and the water coming down
the creek goes through the tubes.
And by the time it,
you know,
it focuses in this one area,
it's spins this thing around
and start to generate.
I want that,
I want to get that crazy.
I watch and he pulls the cord and
it's going on.
Got Electricity 100% from the
creek spinning this generator.
So as long as this
generator keeps working,
he had his lights on the whole,
the whole thing.
It's crazy.
That really is the one thing
that you need is like power.
You know,
it really is the one thing
that separates us from animals.
Well we've somehow or another
just accepted that that's
going to be around even
though it's only been here for 150
years or whatever the hell it's been.
We were so used to it,
you know,
a million years of human
beings and 150 years of power.
We're just like this how we do it.
We got power.
I could see myself going
to my ex girlfriend's house
and just hanging out and
cause she would have like all
the candles in the rural vrs
candles a girl has is directly
proportionate to exactly
how long she will cry.
FDF section.
Yeah.
Girls were prepped a little bit
harder than it dude candles.
Mentos you know there's like 30 candles,
that bitch just going to cry
for a bomb is petroleum base,
you know,
whatever girl Shit.
But uh,
yeah,
we have a lot of different things to
help you in survival situation and I'll
tell you,
you know who really did not
step up for this crisis,
the dogs of New York City because like
every other person in New York has a dog
when it's all of these faggot.
He has a little dogs and I was like,
they've been genetically
belt,
all the cool like Wolf Kahn qualities
that would have helped look gone.
So they were like,
what,
are we going to do any food there
when the snow hit afterwards?
No,
I was already out of there but that was
like a one two punch of like sad fuck
man.
A blizzard.
And the really scary
things that they're saying.
Well,
who's the governor Cuomo?
Andrew Cuomo.
Yes.
Yeah.
He's a good guy though.
He seems like a good guy.
He said something really interesting.
He said,
I don't want to use the
term climate change.
I'm getting,
I'm paraphrasing him because
it's such a loaded topic.
He said,
but you know,
his father had to deal with in 12 years,
he had to deal with
two major storm events.
And he's like,
I've been here for 12 months
and I've had to deal with three.
Wow.
You know,
so he's saying like,
there's,
it's very possible.
Something's going on
the,
I think there's definitely something
going on that's never happened in New York
before.
Well,
you know,
uh,
a buddy of mine,
I assume you know him too,
a big Jay Oakerson.
Yes.
He's a great of him.
Do you know of him?
Okay.
Yeah.
You probably haven't worked with them yet,
but really funny guys toured
with me a couple of times.
His house was wiped out.
He was like in the flood
is flood zones zone A,
whatever,
you know,
it really is weird.
Like when a flood comes at your house.
So I'm lucky.
I like lift up,
you know,
up in that is skyscrapers.
But the scary part about that is like
if the power goes out then you're like
trying to kind of stuck
up there until like,
you know,
whatever happens.
So you're stuck up there
until the water drains out.
Exactly.
You know,
it's like a skeleton,
you know,
basically born.
I believe in the theory that it was a
terrorist attack and I think all the
terrorists are now high.
Whether ladies with beards,
a Neptune,
Lawton.
Well your first part made sense.
The second part just like your Hitler
cat with a fucking dynamite strapped to
his chest.
I don't know what you're trying.
And a lot of people were just basically
milling around a lot like fires,
you know on the street.
Like people making fires and
quicken out on the street,
which I think they should
allow them to do that.
Well why not?
You know,
you keep a sense of a social,
the exact connectedness.
But yeah,
it was bad with their food shortages.
A supermarket or a question
like the first night,
like everybody prepped in terms of like,
you better buy milk and bread.
They always say that milk and bread,
all the,
uh,
you know,
which we're it French toast that we make.
And then like the next day,
you know that you're like,
okay,
there'll be more,
nothing.
There was nothing left.
All the people from downtown who didn't
have access to food came uptown like a
horde and like,
no,
no.
A watchman call it,
it was good that they did it because
they had no food and they kind of swept
through all the Bodega's
and stuff like that.
So it was like wiped out,
you know?
Wow.
That must have been strange.
Yeah.
I mean,
like you always assume in
America there's going to be food.
You know,
the other thing is the cell
phone towers were down,
down.
Even if you had a cell phone,
you couldn't call anybody.
My friend Tommy said he drove,
he drove six hours to
make a cell phone call.
You got to just drive around
until he could find service.
But it was six hours before.
That's crazy.
Yep.
Coco had service though.
Did you see the video?
She was posting of her like in
the rain with ice teas wife.
Oh dear you.
She has special bling
service snapping Sarah.
She had cell phone service.
Yeah,
she had cell phone service
and she has this posting,
these awesome videos of
her in the hurricane,
like rain hitting her
while she's wearing like,
nope,
no clothes.
And she's like,
oh,
it's so rainy outside is great.
That's like a videos.
That's how rap video.
Yeah.
[inaudible]
okay.